they don't actually care about
politicizing these tragedies too soon
because Marjorie Taylor green and Tucker
Carlson and the whole lot of them
immediately politicized it when it was
about clamping down on the trans
community and linking this to what they
call trans women in sports and drag
shows and CRT and all of this sort of
stuff as always they claim to care about
the deficit but they don't they only
care about the deficit when it's a
democrat in the White House they claim
to care about uh election Integrity
except when they try to steal an
election that they lost it's all
projection and similarly they care about
not politicizing mass shootings
except when it's convenient to
politicize a mass shooting